yeah welcome to this video playing
tourist us from Italy let's see my
invites a transposition to a French but
just recently I lost one very terrible
game with the French is white so let's
let's play it really really simple here
the London against them against the the
Dutch it's not not bad really i played
this a couple of times in then over the
board blitz and quite often you um you
get quite good positions okay this is
maybe not the most solid way to to play
but it's it's probably interesting 95
wait where do I put this Bishop here
this looks a bit shaky okay I'll night a
form this is idea okay maybe it looks a
bit unnatural to do that but maybe I
needed need to do do the do it okay it's
probably not so bad King needs to get
out of the sea file of course I want to
engineer some some some g42 to get get
an attack going g4 come on it looks a
crude but maybe maybe this is exactly
the way to go if it takes I have fun
Queen h5 as a possible idea or even take
our Rock g1
Rock g1 could be could be a tricky line
yeah I cannot he cannot take of course
cringes haven't made and Bishop f6 the
screen age five no I like it if you just
if I just get it Rock g4m this attack
will be overwhelming but maybe there are
some some tactical technical refutations
is possible of course I just hoped that
this is working without calculating too
many lines
and don't tell I don't really see em a
complete reputation yeah maybe Knight f6
just Knight f6 protecting the porn but
yeah ok so my night years hanging you
see threatening to take it I could play
95 it's not why not actually just go low
g5 ok yeah this is annoying I don't want
to exchange Queens here could we need
three or something
hmm okay yeah it's not the end of the
world the the Queen trade age seven at
least is hanging
okay let's let's try that if he takes f
takes a very nice and if it takes on f3
I mean okay then the G file is open as
well this will be a good be dangerous
now I can cannot take on f3 would be a
really amazing okay I didn't see that I
didn't see it didn't so I really see
much in this game ah ok need to need to
look back and now hmm it's still as it
still seems seems like a tricky position
hmm yeah I don't know what am i two
pawns down or something
I could have taken on age seven actually
and then crazy form you could have done
that one move before I mean not not
winning or something but really am
getting something going it was much
better move before the apt it is still
dangerous i mean i played this really
like a drunken machine gunner but
sometimes they hit something this is
also hey so which one do i take check
okay 94
I just let's get get back here no I'm an
exchange up so don't need to made any
more directly
hmm
that's slightly slightly annoying
greenedge too so let's I threaten who
have sex again he needs to take now I
think check he really needed to take now
it's a it's competes immediately black
resin immediately over yeah it wasn't
the most correct attack ever but it was
it was interesting at least so what does
the cops a look at four mmm yeah look at
four didn't see that one with the wind
for black yeah of course the computer is
is giving this all the way as winning ya
hear I could have taken here already
instead of age four and i thought this
this is at least the dangerous move
against yeah against the human this is
dangerous definitely the comp wants to
play d Fife and says it's a win but I've
got all pieces on the Kings oh it's not
easy to defend objectively it's probably
not right okay we had to head this and
also giving her this is a win but ok
this loses the Queen g6 yeah it's
difficult to to play in an actual blitz
game d 6 is the computer suggestion
which makes much sense protecting it
from the side until if I go something
like here this is not f 6 yeah not a
very very good game but I've wanted to
to try something aggressive like this
but
it wasn't really wasn't really a sound
alright thanks for watching